hey youtubers is Charlie so in honor of
the flash midseason finale I thought
it'd be fun to do a video on the reverse
flash or reverse flashes you could
consider them part of the flash family
but usually when people talk about the
flash family they're talking about the
hero characters we still don't know who
the version is that the show is going
with it could be incorporating some
multiverse theory they're definitely
mixing and matching things it's none of
the characters that we think it is right
now so we can talk more about theories
whenever I post my episode review
tonight so be sure to subscribe to get
that so now let's talk a little bit
about the man in yellow so the version
of the reverse flash you met first
depends on when you started reading
comics or watching the movies and the TV
shows there are at least five different
versions of the character and another
one if you consider the black flash part
of that lot I will for the purposes of
this video but technically the black
flash is the physical embodiment of
death you know or the negative Speed
Force so it's not really part of the
Thawne lineage so here's everybody from
back to front front being the new 52
universe there's the rival from the
Golden Age Jay Garrick days the original
professor zoom a Oh bard dawn from the
late 1960s the hunter zolomon zoom from
Geoff Johns rebirth era inertia from the
late 1990s and then currently in the new
52 universe the Daniel West zoom the
black flash was also created during the
1990s but subsequent versions of the
character have been used more as like a
counterbalance to the positive flashes
and professor zoom so technically it's
not a villain all their powers are based
on the Speed Force technically hunter
zolomon is a little bit different but
it's all about moving fast through space
and time super fast so you can look at
them all as like a really dysfunctional
Brotherhood of speedsters like a really
terrible fraternity that just Hayes's
the out of you the new TV show
hasn't really given a name to the Speed
Force yet and as of the first episode
Barry Allen has no idea that other
flashes existed before him like Jay
Garrick or will exist in the future
so let's just start with the first one
the first version of the reverse flash
was called the rival his real name was
dr. edward clariss and he was a
professor at the university that Jay
Garrick went to he recreated the
chemical accident that gave Garrick his
powers and then called the formula
velocity-9
he started mass-producing the formula
and wearing a darker version of jay
garrick's costume and committing crimes
but the conceit was is that the
formula was very temporary so eventually
he was caught and thrown in jail in a
subsequent incident klaris ran so fast
that he hit the speed of light and
entered the Speed Force like he became
pure energy
Jeff John's who's a write on the TV show
right now brought that character back
whenever he was writing the Justice
Society comic in the early 2000s I
always forget how Geoff Johns is really
notable for bringing classic characters
back in fact he's the one that brought
Barry Allen back during the rebirth
comic do not be surprised if you see a
lot of classic heroes and villains show
up on the flash and arrow this season
eventually he turned into pure speed
force again and escaped
so he's floating out there somewhere but
technically he's more of a Jake Garrick
enemy he's not really a Barry Allen
enemy next we have the first zoom
character elbahr Thawne known as
Professor zoom
he was an enemy of the Barry Allen flash
during the Silver Age his character was
the start of tying the reverse flashes
to the good flashes in a blood relative
way it really took the idea of the flash
family to a literal place a bard was
from the 25th century so like four
hundred years from now and the way way
far future
he was the start of this causality time
loop that would become a huge part of
all subsequent flash stories so he
started out as this crazy Barry Allen
fan who at that time had been long dead
so he had plastic surgery to make
himself look like Barry then replicated
the accident that gave him flash powers
found the cosmic treadmill and tried to
go back and meet him in real life just
imagine what his tumbler must have
looked like yikes so he miscalculated
the time-travel and ended up arriving a
couple years after Barry Allen had died
he travelled to the flash Museum and
learned that he was destined to become a
criminal and as a result of the stresses
of time travel and learning his true
fate he went completely nuts he tried to
pass himself off as the real Barry Allen
until Wally West beat the crap out of
him and sent him back to the future so
then like way later in the comics they
kind of rebooted the character a little
bit but it still involved a whole lot of
time-travel way way later he started
using the name professor zoom and kept
trying to go back in time to change the
past so that he could defeat the flash
this was also the start of when the
reverse flashes started trying to kill
people in Barry's family so remember the
trailer for the flash TV show we see a
version of the reverse flash was there
when Barry's mother was being murdered
mild spoiler warnings but I'm guessing a
lot of you already know the plot
flash rebirth that was published like
five years ago so I don't worry too much
about spoilers in the comments
especially for stuff that's like super
super old AO Bart on travel back so many
times and heard Barry Allen's family in
so many different ways that finally
Barry just snapped his neck and then
retired to the 30th century I know
they're playing it a bit fast and loose
with time travel and heroes doing awful
things during a Oh Bart Don's era we
also learned that his family descended
from Barry's family eobard was the
descendant of cobalt blue berries secret
twin brother
I know confusing it all happened back in
the comics in the 90s so the doctor who
delivered berry in his twin brother also
delivered this other woman's baby named
Charlene Thawne he accidentally killed
her baby so he secretly gave her Barry's
twin brother and he was raised as a
Thawne the interesting part about all
this is that on the flash TV show they
ticked a pretty boy is named Edward
Thawne we don't know enough about him
yet but he might secretly be related to
Barry due to some weird time travel
paradox stuff going on TV shows tend to
oversimplify really complicated book
plots hint-hint Game of Thrones so we'll
just have to wait and see how the TV
show deals with their connection the
flash rebirth character brought the a Oh
Bart Thawne character back whenever
Geoff Johns brought Barry Allen back and
at the end of all that they severed
thawne's connection to the Speed Force
and lock him up in iron Heights prison
on the TV show that's the place where
Barry's father is in prison so if they
ever do any prison scenes be on the
lookout for a cell marked Thawne and
thus begins the hunter zolomon zoom era
Zollman was a police officer with Wally
West in Keystone City suliman's area of
expertise was criminology in psychology
so he spent all of his time trying to
get inside criminals heads his father
was a serial killer and he had a lot of
bad luck that resulted in his wife
leaving him and getting paralyzed from
the waist down during one of gorilla
grodd's attacks on the city so he had a
legitimately troubled past he was always
a little bit resentful of just being
stuck behind a desk because he was
actually a pretty good police officer
but he always looked up to Wally West
and they were good friends he did know
that he was the flash when zolomon asked
why to change his past to reverse the
accident and he refused zolomon tried to
use the cosmic treadmill himself so of
course it went horribly wrong blew up in
his face and severed his connection to
the timestream giving him the ability to
move through time and space he was able
to travel at supers
he's just like the flash but his powers
were not based on the Speed Force
instead he was moving through times so
whenever he talked his speech would
change speeds causing him to talk in
this really funky way as a result of all
that - he also went pretty insane and
concluded that Wally West refused to
help him because he didn't know real
tragedy
so zolomon went back in time to try and
kill Wally's pregnant wife and even
though it caused a miscarriage while he
was still able to stop him by borrowing
speed from the other flashes so this
brings up a really good point the idea
that flashes can grant their powers or
their speed to other flashes making them
faster we only know about Barry Allen on
the flash TV show right now but it's
possible if another flash shows up they
can make Barry faster so the next
version of the reverse flash to exist
was inertia he was a clone of Bart Allen
he was actually a huge part of the
Infinite Crisis and rogues revenge
storyline before the new 52 reboot so he
is most notable for stealing zooms
powers and then getting the Rogues to
help him kill Bart Allen since evil ends
up turning on itself eventually he of
course went mad then killed hunter
zolomon then himself was killed by the
Rogues who were taking revenge for being
tricked into killing Bart Allen so this
is where we hit the new 52 universe and
current day right now the reverse flash
is actually Daniel West the brother of
iris West he just calls himself zoom he
got his powers from a freak accident
that granted the Speed Force to a bunch
of people during an attack from the
Rogues that's also the same event that
gave the Rogues their real-life powers
on the TV show we've only met iris West
and Detective West so we don't know if
where they're going to be doing the
Daniell character it seems like they're
just going to stick with a modified
flash rebirth storyline for inspiration
but expect to see aspects from all the
different versions of the characters and
I totally would not be surprised if they
combined the Edward Thawne character the
pretty boy character with hunter zolomon
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments below which version of the
reverse flash is your favorite and which
version do you think the show is going
to do so a quick reminder my episode
review will post tonight after the
episode airs we can talk about some
reverse flash theories and that I'll be
doing plenty of bonus videos in the off
season too but arrow the climb is also
going to be tomorrow I'm going to try
and do a bonus video for that too for
Rachel gold just because the story is
supposedly based on a very notable
Batman comic Batman 232 I think to be
specific
if you're on your mobile phone on your
tablet you can click up here for extra
links it's the same as the links over
here
but click here for that review I'll post
it tonight as soon as it airs the
episode 9 review and click here to get
ready for arrow tomorrow thank you so
much for watching so let's all high-five
and shift things into reverse
you